nous voyons la chanson punitive de
l'arbre marin inconnu de Navid
bien proche de votre vie
Je me souviens toujours quand j'étais enfant, je
pensais toujours qu'il y avait toujours quelque chose sous
mon lit,
donc je n'aimerais jamais que je
ne puisse pas avoir une main de  mon lit quand
je dormais ou une jambe ou un pied ils
devaient tous être à l'intérieur du lit dans
le blog technique pour être tagués en dessous
j'avais une imagination très vive je peux remercier
ma mère pour ça mais ouais c'est une
drôle de chose bizarre bizarre  que vous avez quand vous étiez
enfant, je suppose que dans certains, j'ai dû voir
quelque chose à la télévision que je n'aurais pas
dû voir quand j'étais enfant maintenant, je n'ai pas
vraiment beaucoup de phobies, je ne suis pas si
rapide sur les araignées.  Je n'aime pas tellement les araignées,
mais je pourrais probablement m'en remettre si
je devais le faire pour quelque chose, mais Heights, je suis un
peu drôle, mais j'ai surmonté le fait
que je suis allé, je pare, je me suis libéré, j'ai fait du
parachutisme en chute libre récemment, alors oui, je
veux dire des phobies  sont tous ici, vous savez
que c'est le truc avec les phobies, vous pouvez les
surmonter, mais vous ju  st besoin d'avoir
les bonnes personnes et le soutien et vous
savez que vous en parlez la plupart du
temps ouais absolument quand j'étais enfant j'avais tellement
peur des fantômes j'ai toujours eu tellement peur
des fantômes surtout le film le 6n a
paniqué la merde de  moi euh et maintenant
j'ai encore vraiment peur des fantômes - je
crois totalement aux fantômes je dors
dans beaucoup d'Auto - les fantômes des vieux hôtels
existent
et ils ont continué à me faire peur ce qu'ils
font yep notre Footloose celui qui vous déteste le plus tous les
deux est tombé  off car si un bon pour le
venire un arrêt de plus
ne savez-vous rien
ouais ouais ils sont vraiment gros je ne les ai pas
toujours eu là juste quelqu'un
m'a demandé sur le plateau ce que je faisais DRI
pourraient-ils être comme pourquoi t'as
j'avais toujours tes crocs ils pensaient que j'avais les
faux j'étais comme si je n'en avais pas et
ce sont mes dents c'est un ouais c'est très
étrange je veux dire j'étais évidemment destiné
à jouer un vampire à un moment de ma
vie